[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys and
welcome back to the leia highlands show
powered by icon
plus so icon is excited to announce
icon5 so it's a super easy staking um
and earning service where you can
receive yield on icon ethereum bitcoin
tether
and if you do join early you can
actually get up to twenty percent fixed
term and apy
so always great news coming out of icon
there i also want to say thank you to my
sponsors block five so
as you guys probably know already i use
them um i earn up to 8.6
interest on my usdc uscc is a stable
coin
pegged to the us dollar so there you go
um if you're interested in that
um you can actually get i think at the
moment around 250 dollars if you join so
i'll leave a link for that
in the comments in the description in
all the places you go to find a link so
i'll leave that there
um and before we start the show because
i do have a very very exciting guest
um i also want to say a quick shout out
to coinflip so
coinflip are doing some incredible work
across the states to push bitcoin mass
adoption
they have nearly a thousand atms um
across 45 different states um
giving everybody access to bitcoin so i
think that's some incredible stuff that
they're doing
so today i have a really cool guest
somebody who is actually i'm not sure if
you know this um one of my favorite
people in the space
it is c z how are you doing
hello how are you i'm good how are you
pretty good pretty good i didn't know i
didn't know that your favorite person
you are and let me tell you why you're
one of my favorite people in this way so
i think
you know a lot of the time these big
ceos big
founders they i find that there's quite
like a distance between them and the
community
and there's not that interaction
that you that you would like and i find
that you're
one of the most i mean loads of people
say this you're one of the most um
active people
on on twitter and you reply to people we
can interact with you and i think
it's such a small community so it
kind of seems odd when there isn't that
connection do you know what i mean
uh yeah i think well for me it's really
interesting as well so um
i learned a lot from our users it's a
good way for me to interact
actually i'm not a socializing hub so
like many people like some hubs know a
lot of people
i actually don't know that many people
so i don't really socialize with that
many people but i just find it easy on
twitter to talk to our users and
talk to our community just talk to our
supporters it's just
it's just easy so um yeah for me it's
pretty it's pretty simple yeah
no it's really nice and you know as
somebody in the space
i mean i totally appreciate it and i
know loads of people do appreciate it as
well
um but i've got loads of questions for
you because
loads of people know you as cz the guy
from finance and all this stuff but
i want to know more about you so how
would you define yourself
um so yeah i mean i would just think of
myself as a
ex-developer turned entrepreneur um
kind of have a little bit of an
international experience in my early
days and then
got lucky had a really strong team that
executed well
and then now i have a chance to to help
increase the freedom of money all around
the world
and this is a this is a great
opportunity i'm really i'm really
humbled by it so
that's that's who i am so i'm doing
doing my thing
yeah absolutely you are doing your thing
and you're obviously very successful
and you know even before crypto you were
doing
a lot of stuff in tech so give me
three principles that you would say
you've learned from
all of this that you can sort of take
with you
and i guess people who are also looking
to get into crypto looking to maybe do
something like yourself what are three
main principles
um i think for me um i think the first
principle
from for myself i do have a couple
principles i could share um
yeah but like i don't know i don't know
if the principles will really help or
not
but i i do try to be fair in life uh so
uh
where whatever business partner we work
with i do like this might sounds cheesy
we do try to
uh uh structure win-win deals um
i do view most uh corporations to be
long-term
so uh we want to be long-term uh
successful we only
we want to be long-term benefiting a
long-term deal
typically you wanted to work on for both
sides because otherwise it's not going
to last
same thing as when we hire when we hire
people who work in the
in the team and when we work with
external people et cetera
so also when how we treat our users our
community
et cetera so um so i think trying to be
fair is probably the first
principle that i really recommend people
and i do try to follow that
fairly strictly myself i don't i never
try to take advantage of people
um i also don't try to let people take
advantage of us but
um sometimes it happens but that's okay
i think that's the first one the second
one is probably just being really really
focused
so i try to remove all distractions
anything that's not really important
so i have no car i don't have to take
care of insurance
fixing cars parking i don't have to
worry about all of that
um i don't really have a lot of time
consuming hobbies um so i don't really
play games anymore
um so i just really and i don't have any
external investments outside of finance
i never invest personally
finance as an organization investing in
different type of
organizations and we have a team to do
that so i don't have anything personally
i don't have any personal investments i
don't even
have a house anymore so i keep
everything very simple when i go to a
restaurant i
if if i couldn't pick up something i
like in the first five seconds i just
pick the third item on the menu
so i try to make it more yeah so i just
try to make everything really really
simple so that i can focus on one thing
which is binance right now
so um so so that's that's the second
principle so i remove
a lot of the distractions that most
people may have
the third one is probably in this
industry just got to be really positive
so number one is we being positive and
being fair is slightly different so
we we never tried to target anyone we're
not against anyone any organization any
government any regulator we would
we're not into that um and we're just
trying to build value which
we're just trying to try to contribute
whatever we can into like this may sound
kind of cheesy but honestly we're just
trying to contribute to this industry
contribute to society
um we if we if we don't have that such
strong abilities then we'll just
contribute a little bit if
now we can contribute a little bit more
so um so just being positive and also on
a day like this
being positive is pretty important so i
would say that's probably the
three things i would i would say that
are really important to me
and i try to follow them to the best
extent i can
yeah i think those things things are
really important and
it's not cringy in the slightest it's
not cliche
um i think that's insane so you don't
have a car and you don't have
an actual house that you own essentially
no i don't i don't have a car don't have
a house
it's my life is much simpler so i don't
have to take care of i
had a house at one point it took me six
months to sell it it was like so much
trouble
so i now i don't have to worry about it
i just you know i rent
um i live in hotels it's fine oh my gosh
you know that's really interesting
because they sort of say that is the new
world there's this idea that you've got
to get on the property ladder
but that seems to be this old kind of
mentality
i think it depends on lifestyle so if
you live in one place uh for a while i
think having a place
is good and if you have like you know
raising kids and stuff like that
um but for me like i travel so much and
even if i even if i buy a house or car
i'm not going to be using 90
of the time it's just gonna sit there
and rust and then like
i'm still gonna be using uber um grab
and all this other uh
ride sharing services i'm still gonna be
staying in hotels et cetera so
um for me it doesn't it doesn't really
help and it just creates a lot
of mental baggage that i need to take
care of i yes for me it's much easier
without those things
yeah i absolutely hear you i think
that's really interesting and i think
i'm definitely gonna consider that um
because i'm always moving around as well
and you know i'm thinking houses cars
and this but you mentioned something
really interesting you said not to be
taken
advantage of and being fair so i wanna
i wanna learn a little bit more about
this because i think you know not just
in work but in life in general there's
this really difficult line between
sort of being fair being honest and
being kind um and then
that kindness and can sort of be taken
for granted and or can be mistaken for
weakness
so how do you find that line i think
number one is like for anybody i
interact with personally or have a work
relationship of any kind either they're
working with part as part of binance or
as a partner with binance etc
we do we do try to structure deals that
work for both sides so
once like for example if i if my team
member says it's easy we got this really
good deal to work with this
other entity um and this is why it's so
good for us i always ask why is it good
for them
um so i need to understand that deal
structure so that it's good for both
sides it makes sense
so um yeah things have to make sense and
then um
um i i believe that look if if the other
party asks for a lot that
we don't think is fair then we just walk
away um it's a free world
in most places um so we just walk away
and we try not to be taking advantage
advantage of
um there are certain times where we do
have to defend ourselves a little bit
and by sometimes even like fighting back
a little bit
but like that's you that if for binance
or for myself that's all
that's almost always because somebody
attacked us first first
so when those things happen then we have
no choice but um
it's not something we want to do it's
not something i enjoy but look
um sometimes you have to so yeah
yeah and speaking and speaking of fair
and and all of that i think you can
absolutely sort of like
hold your word to that because i
remember you guys were hacked was it in
2019 and
it was like that seven bitcoin reserves
or whatever it was i don't remember but
you had that reserves and you were able
to you know give that back to your
customers
yes so um yeah so we always we always we
we always want to protect our users and
be fair being very fair to them so if we
get hacked that's our responsibility we
should cover it
and also two years ago there was a
hacker
that attacked us and then we put out a
bounty that's kind of like a
aggression from us but we were attacked
first and we actually um we just granted
that bounty like 250k us dollars worth
of um i think
they took bnb um so we just granted that
recently
and um so that's that's uh because uh
the
somebody was actually uh two guys
actually helped us track those
guys down and through proper legal
procedures
they were actually put on some sanction
list um so
that's not that's not a situation where
we had to defend ourselves by putting
out a bounty
to hunt for some hackers but we would
not we would not
aggressively do we would not proactively
do that unless we're attacked so
we were attacked two years ago so yeah
yeah you have to do what you got to do
to protect yourselves and your customers
i think you guys you know you show that
you do that but
moving on a little bit i want to go back
to your early life and understand how
you became
cz so you grew up in china but then you
moved to canada and from what i've read
your father was a professor who was
exiled from china so if you don't mind
me asking i'm really interested to know
what happened
sure um yeah so i can go a little bit
more detail than
what i went through previously so
probably people here a little bit more
um so i become cz because most people
can't really pronounce my name
very well so so that's probably why um
but
um so i um i was born in china i moved
to canada
uh with my parents when i was 12. and at
the time my father was a professor
so my father's life is actually pretty
interesting so my father
um my father got into university and the
first year he got into into university
was the cultural revolution in china so
they basically canceled all universities
and said look go back to the farmland
learn the core values of life learn how
to find farm land
um and my father came from like the
countryside so um
so um uh of uh six years later he didn't
attend a single class he was trying to
study on his own
and then um after the cultural
revolution he applied for
a um a master's degree in university of
british
british columbia so that's in vancouver
canada
and um so he got he actually got
accepted because he was studying on his
own
so my father is kind of a bookworm and
then he went to continue to study a
master program and then a phd
um so my father was always like a like a
student of some type
and then eventually became like a
professor um so i
uh when i went to canada um he was still
that was just before he got his phd
phd degree this is when i was 12. so we
were living on his master's program
uh um i don't know salary or or or or
professor income
uh not professor like the pro his
professor was giving him some like
income so it wasn't much um it was not
we were not
super poor but we're not rich by any
means so like we were
we were we were like friendly very very
modest so that's kind of like my
my sort of growing up that's my father's
um
um that's kind of my father's um like
his life in a very you know very you
know very
a very simplified version so my father's
always a brokeworm um
and he he's always like academic uh
never good
not very good in business but he's like
always just sort of
you know lived a very simple life
so i kind of i came i kind of came from
that my father did encourage me to
work from very early on um so i worked
at
mcdonald's was my first job i think i
was 14 15.
um so that was actually under the legal
age of working in canada which is 16 but
mcdonald's has some kind of
has some kind of exception that they are
they do they are able to
take young young kids young teenagers to
work
and that was a really really good
experience so um i
i worked really early and then um
um and then i basically had different
jobs ever since then um
not continuously when i was like in
school when i was like in college in
school like when i studied a study and
then this in the summer
i i worked so i've traveled quite a lot
even myself
so i moved in china and then moved to
canada and then
went to in canada moved into different
places so i was always like
i never really stayed in one city for
very long um and i was moving between
countries as well so
when i was um in college um
my my second intern job i went to japan
tokyo to work so i was like traveling
in different countries so i think that
international um
experience actually really really helped
me now
before i never really i never realized
how valuable that was but
by looking back now having that
international sort of exposure
uh really helped me to get into crypto
understanding understand bitcoin
understand cross-border
remittances transactions so yeah i mean
a lot
yeah you know short version like kind of
long already but
um but that but that's kind of what
shaped me in my early years
yeah i think you make two really
interesting points right so it's kind of
moving from country to country you your
family and you probably both experienced
the issue
you know with money it's an absolute
nightmare having to
you know change your money here change
your money there you can't get a bank
account and all this stuff
um so i think that's actually insane
because you probably really
felt that growing up and now you know
you're one of the biggest people in this
space
driving it forward you know so you must
have really felt the need for that
um but then as well you know you're
obviously really international
um you know i often find that i often
find that a lot of the time people who
haven't left
their own country and for whatever
reason sort of unfortunately
lack a certain kind of world view just
because they haven't had the opportunity
to see
anything else um so you know when you're
working in this space and you're dealing
with all these different people um
yeah you know you've had that experience
which which i think is really cool but
i'm interested in your father
what happened why why was he exiled from
china
so he like wasn't really accident but
basically due to the cultural revolution
he didn't spend a single day in
university and then when the
cultural revolution was over there was a
program for there was a trend or a
program for
people to apply to go overseas
especially for the academics um
and so my father applied and so it was
actually a pretty difficult process
even for my so you like well we can get
into a little bit more detail so my
father went to canada in 1984.
um i went to canada six years later five
six years later
in 1989. um there was a little bit of
history
there as well so um so my father went on
a student visa
and then in china back then it was very
difficult to get a passport
so it took like almost i remember it
took like three or four years for us to
get a passport
and once you have a passport it's
extremely difficult to get a visa
so like visa was very very limited back
then um but then
in 1989 there was a tmn
square event where the student was
protest and there were some
uh some issues and right after that that
incident
um the foreign the foreign government
relaxed the
visa require restrictions and there was
there was
like lines around the canadian embassy
in beijing like
it circles the embassy like and you have
to wait for two days to get it
so basically you let you you wait for 48
hours on the street like with a with a
chair
with a plastic chair and everything but
um but they they were granting
visas so um i got my visa i was 12 i was
following my mom so i got my visa in
that process
um and then got the visa and so um so
the
the 1984 uh student event is on june 4th
and i left china in on on august 9th
so i remember those days really clearly
because those are pretty significant
events
and so that actually taught me some
really interesting experiences where
like moving between countries etc
you don't really live in one country
there's a world out there
so my father um my father so when i went
when i went to canada he was still just
finishing up his
phd thesis so i remember attending his
thesis
just look watching him talk and stuff
like that
so he already had a 12 year or 12 year
old kid and um so i couldn't really
understand very much but i kind of
unders
i kind of i got a gist of it um and then
um so my father just always had
more academic jobs like never never he
was never an entrepreneur so he
um so he he was always like an academic
academic guy
um so let a pretty simple life um yeah
so
that's that's kind of yeah afterwards
yeah he he
afterwards once he got a phd degree and
then he settled down and
he eventually went to work um for uh
he studied dual physics so like um so
basically like crazy integration
formulas um to
figure out how where the oils are uh
under on
under under under the under the earth so
he worked for a couple of
oil companies he actually went to texas
uh houston to
um to work for a couple oil companies
and then went back to canada
so um so he actually had a he always had
a more of a academic position
yeah so that's kind of my father and
just like going back a little bit the
most interesting thing well it's all
super interesting but something which
really
really stood out to me um was the job
position as a mcdonald's employee
at 14. so that's insane because
number one just look at you know how
much you've achieved since then but also
you know
you are like under under the working age
like you said the working age was 16. so
when you're working in mcdonald's um
because you know
people it's really awful but i mean i
don't know if you have the obviously i'm
from the uk and there's this stupid joke
in the uk
about people working at mcdonald's it's
just that's just the joke that there is
in the uk i don't know if it's a global
thing i have no idea
um but you know when you're working
there did you ever think
that you would be able to achieve what
you've achieved and you know be
one of the most successful people in
such a growing space and also absolutely
like you just can't knock people working
at mcdonald's i think
you know working from 14 that's just
insane
good on you yeah so i never really
thought i would be a billionaire i just
never crossed my mind even like even
like four years ago
just like any any time before four years
ago even before three and a half years
ago just never crossed my mind
um so i never had such strong uh
ambitions
but i i i do know that i want to be
financially free
but not maybe not at that age using that
that term but i
at that at that time i probably just
thought i want some more pocket money to
buy some
to buy some stuff that i want to buy um
but uh i do know that i do
i need to work for i do need i need to
work for for uh for money
what's interesting though is um at my
age uh so my my dad is a pretty unique
case
in uh and i was a pretty unique case in
canada um
at the time most of the people most of
people from from mainland china
to canada like a student immigrates
they're much younger so they're like
27 20 something my father's 40
40 something approaching 50s so i was
12. and
um so it's either like yeah like 20
something like university grads et
cetera
applying for master's student students
and they have kids that are much younger
it's like maybe like just babies so
there's no no
very few kids from like at age 12 in
canada at that time
so my friends were um they were they
were asians they were like taiwanese
guys and uh hong kong cantonese hong
kong guys
um in in vancouver there's a lot of them
they they do speak chinese
and uh and then there's the sort of
caucasians to canada's
immigrant country right so there's
people from everywhere from the world so
i'm i was very tuned into the
international
sort of uh scene i was so this is also
why i'm very comfortable
getting used to uh talking to people
around different parts of the world
and then there's uh but the uh the
taiwanese guys and the cantonese guys
they all they were all
investing immigrants so their parents
are usually like investing a couple
million dollars in canada
and then um to get the citizenship and
uh the taiwan guys
typically their their parents are
doctors in taiwan in taiwan they're
making very decent money they usually
buy like a couple million dollar house
in canada and usually invest in some
business to get the
to get the visa so they they were
relatively rich
so um those guys are driving like really
nice cars
not super nice but like you know volvo's
sometimes porsche
um so i i wasn't able to afford a car
when i
when i was a like when i turned 16 got
my driver's license i wasn't
so for me like i was like i was
you know very i was on on a very modest
uh financial situation where like a lot
of my friends are relatively well off
so i had that that little bit of a
comparison but i
i never thought of becoming a
billionaire but i just wanted to sort of
be financially just sort of be well off
and not like uh
i didn't want to be ranked super high
but just right well off
so that's kind of the um the environment
where's that or at least
the way i remember some of my some of my
early mentality
but kudos to uh a lot of my friends from
then
many of those kids worked in mcdonald's
as well so the the
guys i have with like the taiwanese guys
cantonese guys the caucasians they
worked in mcdonald's as well
um so like some of the guys were driving
porsche to mcdonald's
i love it i love it that's brilliant
that's so brilliant um
so you mentioned financial freedom right
so like that's this fancy term that we
love to use
um but you know back in the day what did
financial freedom actually
mean to you did it just mean the ability
to sort of like drive your porsche to
mcdonald's
uh and i'm joking or do or did it just
sort of mean like literally you know
own your own assets um i think i only
understood that term much much later to
be honest
so now like um so back then it was just
really just to earn some pocket money
um so that yeah just hang out with
friends etc
um and um uh much later on i would say
like when i was starting to getting jobs
like from when i was in university like
getting
intern jobs i was i started to reach
that poor dad
um and then thought about walking what
does financial freedom mean
um so uh i i learned about passive
income
at a relatively early age as well so i
was looking at how so how do i generate
like so that's the
reach that part of that book um but then
um
like i think uh even until when i was 30
something i think that's kind of
when i slowly kind of had a relatively
stable financial situation et cetera so
uh
and then i think back then i would say
look if even if you have if you ask me
four years ago if you ask me what
financial freedom means i would say
probably like five to ten million
dollars is probably enough
for most for me for most people um look
if you have 10 million dollars
above 10 million dollars you're not
going to need you're not going to spend
all that money
um well like depending on what you do
you could yeah
yeah but like to live to to maintain to
maintain a pretty decent living standard
you don't you don't need that much
well 10 million is not a it's not a
small amount so
so that's kind of how like like i didn't
really understand it
at that young age but like later on
that's kind of even four years ago that
would be my
that would be my standard so you know
that's only four years ago and
bitcoin is i mean what do we call it 12
years old now
more or less 12 years old yeah so what
do you think your life would have looked
like if
you know bitcoin had never been invented
i mean i know you were obviously in tech
anyway and you were already making huge
moves anyway for yourself but
what would your life have looked like
you know if bitcoin would never be
invented
i don't know um yeah that's a that's a
very tough one
in a kind of a hypothetical situation i
don't know i probably would try some
like i knew i knew i knew i'm a startup
guy um so um
after working at large companies i i was
like
no i'm not gonna i'm not gonna be able
to work in large companies um it's just
it's just a bit too slow um so i i i
would i would be
probably uh doing some tech startup and
maybe like today maybe
ai i tried social media i didn't didn't
do anything there
uh i didn't do anything successful there
um so probably today would be some like
some ai stuff probably a struggling
entrepreneur um
who knows
yeah i mean sorry i just wanted to
unmute my mic it's quite loud here
um but i mean and you also mentioned
passive income and i think that's really
an interesting point because passive
income is sort of something which i
think everybody can achieve
um but not everybody knows how to
achieve it so
how did you have that penny sort of drop
moment just because
people often think they have to trade
time for dollars
but that's not quite the case is it no
that's absolutely not the case so
basically today uh
well in chinese desert there's a very
simple saying if you're working for
money
um you have a very you have you're a
very limited ceiling
how much time you can work so even like
for example even if you have a very high
pay-per-vision profession like lawyers
doctors
you learn decent you earn very decent
money but the minute you stop well
you won't have savings but the minute
you stop working you stop earning
then that's not a very sustainable
situation and it's not scalable
so um it's um so but of course if your
doctor you can
you can start a clinic and hire people
but then the minute you hire somebody
to work as a team etc then then you're
not
only working uh you're not only trading
your time um
to to get money um and then if you if
you if you if you
if you buy an apartment rent it out then
that's generating passive income
ideally you want the rent to be able to
cover your mortgage payments and
so then this way you have some positive
cash flow and the more
the more of those situations you have
the better the better off you are
and um um so like um i talked a guy
off buying an iphone 12 pro max like a
couple days ago on twitter
the guy was debating between selling his
uh bmb or and to or
or uh or to buy it to buy an iphone and
obviously because he was so recognizing
on twitter that there must be a pretty
significant amount of money for him i
said look if it's a skin because
if it's that kind of significant portion
of uh amount of money for you
don't buy a depreciation depreciating
asset right so you want to buy something
that's
that has potential to appreciate so um
so that guy is a very
very dedicated uh bmb supporter so
not not not difficult to talk him off
that at all
um um and then the bmd price dropped
today so
hopefully he's still no i'm sure he's
okay he's a long-term holder so
um so he's okay and uh but uh i think
people need to understand
that passive income uh is really
important like uh the minute that you
have something generating income for you
or potentially have
uh gains for you that you don't have to
work yourself the more of those you have
the better
um so that's really really important so
i think
a lot of people don't understand that
and they just like they they spend they
trade their time to for
for for money and then they spend it um
that's
that's a very limited way to uh to to
achieve financial freedom
and that's a very hard way to achieve
financial freedom
yeah i'm totally with you and you know
sort of generating that passive income
is something which i've sort of only
recently
come across i mean i'm only in my 20s so
it's something which um that idea has
recently just
popped out and i'm sort of like learning
more about it and understanding how i
can do that
i think it's such a shame though that um
you know we're not sort of taught
that there's another way of doing things
you know we're always taught that we
have to be
in the system and you know be a product
of the system and work for the
industrialists and so on but i won't go
on
um i want to know a little bit more
actually about binance so
like you said you know you were sort of
intact before but where did the idea
come from and also where did the name
come from
uh okay so the idea is the idea is
really not a new idea i think
almost everybody i met in the crypto
industry or at least every entrepreneur
i met in the crypto industry wanted to
start a
cryptocurrency exchange at some point um
so the idea is really old
and talked about in 2013 um
jonah joined the exchange in 2014 and
then left that exchange
they thought about starting a new
exchange in 2015 um
thought it was a bit early and then 2017
um
uh we thought that time was right um at
the time poloniex and blue tracks are
doing really really
not not high volumes like in today's
terms but back then it was like pretty
decent volumes
a couple hundred million dollars a day
uh in in trading volumes and they
like back then i think the fees much
higher like they were like like one
percent or something so that
so back then the industry was like was
not small
uh already so 2017 without the time was
right
um the name binance came in 2017. i
didn't have the name before
um so um we had a couple of different
names and then i actually did come up
with a binary's name
um so like bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin
finance bid finance blockchain finance
and then binary finance binary and
finance have the most overlap
in the number of letters um if we if we
move it if we replace the b
with uh we if we replace the f in
finance with b
so that's uh i came up with that and
then um
uh the domain was was just sold
uh two months ago uh um so then uh
we tried to talk to the guy and then i
think the guy actually only charged us
like a couple thousand dollars so we got
the domain
so that's how it started at the
beginning i wasn't even sure about the
name
we had a couple of different candidates
really yeah um but um worked out
worked out okay so far so yeah
absolutely and also this is just like a
side point i also think the colors are
fantastic
absolutely brilliant yellow and black
like you guys are ahead of the time
yellow and black
just from a branding standpoint yellow
and black are sort of like a new
a new duo um so i think i think you did
great on that but
after launching in july 2017 so after
eight months you guys actually became
the biggest exchange in crypto so
how did you do that that's something
everybody is trying to do i've got
friends that are setting up exchanges
um but eight months wow yeah um
so to be honest when we first started we
thought we would get lucky we'll be
lucky if we can get in the top 10 within
three years
so that's kind of the target that we had
um so it's not that like
we wanted we we aimed for it right away
and we wanted to be the number one
exchange in the world
um but so we didn't really we actually
didn't really have
such uh as professional as professional
goals or like really ambitious goals
but um i do think that uh we just try to
do
what we're good at and while we try to
do our best to provide the best product
and service so it's really
in my in my view it's really really
basic so when we first started
um there's really only two crypto
there's many crypto crypto exchanges but
there's really two big ones
that's poloniex and b tracks and both of
them uh
only have a pc version and even on the
pc version on the website if you want to
trade you have to scroll back and forth
you have to look at the price on top and
then scroll to the bottom to
enter to enter numbers and then so it's
not a very
in my view it's not a very good
experience to be honest um so we
designed one full screen
um you don't have to scroll at all um
you can see the charts you can see the
history trade so everything you need to
do is on that screen
and you can trade um so that's like a
user experience optimization
and also um we really we launched the
mobile apps very quickly
and we also made our website work
relatively well on mobile
mobile web version and also those two
exchanges are only available in english
so basically they were located in the
u.s and they just service us users it's
a big market
but we thought that's like well u.s at
20 of the global gdp that's 80
gdp outside of of us
so and we were based in asia so we
thought we want to target the
the other ones so we launched nine
languages very quickly and today we
support 22 languages
so we're like like product wise we just
thought there was like a there's a lot
of
slack well there's a lot of room there's
a lot of like on unclaimed territory
that we can try so we did that we also
had a pretty
we also had a very decent uh matching
engines really fast
like it's noticeably fast even when even
even when you trade manually price not
already get a confirmation it's really
really fast so people like it
um the other thing is service so product
and service is really basic
back in 2017 um if before binance if you
submit like if you submit a sport ticket
on any of the exchanges you're probably
going to be waiting for a month
for the reply and this is when you have
money stuck on exchange or
have some kind of issue on financial
platform basically
so we thought that's kind of extreme we
can probably try to do better it's
actually pretty difficult to do
um but we did set a set a target of 20
maximum 24 hours for the response
ideally within within an hour um and
then we just hired a lot of guys
um we we wrote a lot of faqs we tried to
make the system as
easy to understand as possible um and we
were servicing like
like uh like a dozen languages back then
22 languages now so
it's it's difficult but we we did we did
do it
and then actually after that um a lot of
other
exchanges copied us so now the service
level in the industry is much better
which is good for everyone which is also
good for us because it brings more
people in
um so we were also the first exchanges
to do a number of things like the um
uh the gas distributions like if one
coin use another coin
um like they what what people could now
call staking
or airdrops uh we were the first
centralized exchange to support that
before that if you have one coin who's
generating another coin
to change that doesn't distribute that
second coin to you we thought
that's a pretty simple mathematical
exercise that we can do that just
distribute that
um so we did that um we did that first
with neil and that attracted a lot of
the new
uh community to us so that's so there's
a lot of little things we did it's
nothing too magical
everything's like pretty basic um and
then just a lot of time on twitter
people seem to like it so um that's
interesting yeah well i told you
i i told you i told you twitter is you
know people love it people love you for
interacting with them um
but that that's really interesting
you're it's the little things
you know it's the little user
experiences it's that little little that
can get my words out can i it's the
little touches that you do
um and i think that's really important
and actually i love to hear
how um you know a free market
competition and all this stuff has sort
of raised the bar
so like you said um now
people respond within 24 hours because
you guys set that standard
so that's super cool but with all of
that going on all these different
languages and everything
how involved are you in the day-to-day
runnings of finance
i'm really not that involved anymore so
like i can literally
be off like i could turn off my phone i
could be off the internet for probably
like i don't know a week or a month
and binance will be totally fine um i
think a lot of users may panic because
i don't know just just the mentality but
i'm no longer really involved on the
day-to-day operations um we have a
really strong team now the team size is
not small either
we we just passed surpassed 1500 people
globally and including the angels the
angels don't get paid
they don't get paid a salary so if
including the angels probably over 1800
people now so it's a pretty large team
um they're very very self-sufficient uh
with distributed teams so every
everybody does their own thing and
somehow it just works together
so um i get i get i get involved in
things when we gotta make
like a so i don't even look at
investment deals until the last minute
and they said look cece we're gonna
invest a couple million dollars here so
like
okay sounds good um so uh and then i get
involved in
like i get involved more like uh i'm
getting more and more
now i'm trying to learn more of this
sort of um how to optimize
organizations um so i try to experience
we experiment with different
different ways so i do try to talk to
people more um but just like hey how's
it going
anything you want to talk about not
specifically hey you you need to do this
and that
so i try to like talk to people just um
more just to just just to see what ways
can we optimize the organization but
um like running mine is like really not
like the
um and like normally so what happens now
when something happens at minus like
even today when there was some like lag
uh some data data center issues i just
get told what to tweet
so just see you thing okay tweeting it
so uh yeah so i'm not i'm not really i'm
not really not involved on the
day-to-day operations now
i have a leadership question actually um
i know that you're not fully involved in
it now but obviously you were
so in terms of you know running this
successful business and this
startup at the time and really you know
lifting it off the ground
how important well of course leadership
is important but what kind of leadership
would you say is important were you
micromanaging
were you um did you empower people to
sort of um you know make them feel like
valuable members of the team
what kind of ethos did you install in
the company
yeah so um yeah i'm i was never
micromanager so i'm
terrible at managing details um and um i
do give people a lot of freedom so
i my my my my style is like i give
people a lot of freedom
um and um they can make mistakes they
can they can they can fail businesses
they can fail projects but as long as
they
as long as they work hard and try hard
so my ethos has always been giving
people a lot of
freedom um and then um uh
i do in the early days i do set even
today i still set the sort of general
direction where we're going like what
things we should do is should not do
like just more on the rules side not not
specific tasks and specific
things but just okay look we should
never hurt our users so
make it if this decision involves um
hurting our users or not then don't
it's pretty obvious um and then um
i do think that finding the right people
is really really important
so getting the right team in place and
then
making sure that they work together well
and making sure that
the team is really passionate and they
um
so i think getting the right people in
is really really important i
i do think i do do a decent job on that
front
um and getting the organic right people
into the right seats i actually do less
of
they want to get people in they find
their own seats um sometimes not ideal
but then
whatever um i i don't spend a lot of
time on strategy so this is something
that's uh
maybe a little bit counter-intuitive but
for me it was very clear this is the
direction we're going we don't we don't
spend
we don't spend much time at all on
discussing strategy stuff
um we we focus a lot more on execution
so just
like how do we do this thing you know
this is where we want to go
and how do we do this um so not not so
much on what we need to do or not but
more like a
like like it's pretty easy to figure out
what to do but just
how to do it um in the early days well
even i think even now i still do
i still i i believe i still do lead by
example um i
even though i don't get involved but i i
have like uh somewhere between 15 to 16
calls every day
just like when just just conference
calls just phone calls to people
um and then i um i work i work
relatively long hour i don't really call
it work i just view this part of my life
yeah so um yeah so i have calls at uh 11
p.m
right now it's like actually so now it's
10 p.m for me 10 45
p.m for me um so like but this is normal
working hour if i'm not talking to you
i'll be talking to somebody on my team
or
or doing something so even though i
don't get involved in the operations but
i do talk to people i
i'm always online i'm always i'm always
around um so people see that and people
and the guys will report to me directly
and they all work those hours so the
like uh i can ping them like at one am
um they usually
usually from like one to two until like
seven or eight so do those however
sometimes we can't find them but
outside of those hours or we can always
find them
um so um i do literally i do have a
i believe our team do have a very hard
working uh
mentality so um i think the the the
leaders should set the tone
uh for that um i think there's no
shortcut for hard work for hard work
so other than that yeah i think that's
pretty much yeah other than that i don't
have a lot of other sort of
secrets or uh good things or or like um
wisdom yeah so yes i think it's pretty
basic yeah
yeah i think um so so many interesting
things that you know you mentioned it's
all about getting the right people
in and you know i i'm you know i don't
own a company like that obviously but
you know just from my personal
experience within work
it's come it's so true it's so hard to
find the the right people that you fit
with and you know you share a vision and
when you find them you don't want to let
them go and you have to sort of like
instill
the right ethos so that they stay and
they have they help build something
amazing
um so what's the vision for finance then
for finances i think it's pretty simple
um uh so we
we really just want to help build
infrastructure in this industry so to
help this industry grow
and the reason we want to do that is we
we want to increase the freedom of money
so i i strongly and i think our team all
believes that
um if you look at history anytime that
we increase we're able to increase
freedom of something without sacrificing
other things um the human civilization
the
the our quality of life improves so from
like
freedom from slavery freedom of speech
freedom of press
um freedom of information um and
um so anytime we can increase those
freedom but today we don't we don't have
a lot of freedom on money
um uh we get this all kind of problems i
want to i won't go into
so that so that's that's kind of what we
want to try to grow
this industry and we want to build
infrastructure to help people
uh use crypto more and have more access
to crypto
and right now the biggest the biggest
application is obviously the exchange
right now
but we don't view that as i don't think
that's going to be always the case there
are many other
infrastructure services that could be
potentially be built and provided
and we don't have to provide every
single one of them we want to provide a
few
good ones that we're good at so
potentially hopefully in the future i
don't know
payments is a very obvious one that
hasn't really taken off
to be honest um that's a cross-border
with cross-border remittances
um even gaming there's many different
infrastructure services that we can try
uh we probably will fail at a number of
them hopefully we'll be successful in a
few
um so that's kind of the the the
direction finance is going
i like that um you know just do a
million different things and one of them
will stick you know
and just because yeah and you know and
it's kind of like when people start a
company they often say
you know it doesn't matter if all of the
you know you started three or four
companies and they all failed
your fourth one might be the one which
beats every company in the world so you
just don't know
um but as a side point actually how did
you first hear about bitcoin i read a
funny story
um apparently you sold at your house for
one million dollars
um to put it all into bitcoin in 2013
what on earth is going on here yeah so
um
bobby lee who was the ct a ceo of
btc china uh he was just above joining
btc china in 2013
uh that was in like june july um so um i
i played program with him so um he he
comes to my house to play program
actually
him and he's um eventually later on
investor
ron tao who's a managing director of
live speed in china
um so we're playing poker um and they
were saying well okay now he's going to
quit his job from
uh he has a pretty decent job so he was
going to quit his job to join the
startup with two guys
um the two original founders btc china
he's going to become the ceo
and this they're running a bitcoin
exchange uh and he says cz you gotta you
should buy
you should you should look into bitcoin
and and in fact he said um
you should convert you should you should
convert ten percent of the net worth
into bitcoin
um you may go to there's a there's a
decent chance you'll go to zero i think
so you lose ten percent
uh there's a higher chance you will go
10x so then you double
um so okay that's pretty serious uh so
so then i started looking into it and um
so
and then ron runs how light speed
ventures invested in btc china
pumping 5 million dollars back then a
pretty large sum for the industry back
then
and then um so i was like okay that's
pretty serious so i started reading
about bitcoin um started reading about
repo actually uh
uh ron was also like looking at a report
and i said i should look into it i did
um and then so i really liked it and
then um but
uh the thing uh so that was like july
starting july i was investing a little
bit so i was buying a little tiny bit i
was like
i bought like one bitcoin which where
did you buy from
uh actually i bought it i bought it on
btc china actually
um it was it was really hard getting
money in and then i
also bought it i also used mongoox among
us at the fiat channel um
in japan um so actually i still have
some money stuck
in mongols but
anyway so um so but i was learning and
playing with it and i really liked it i
i like i come from a technology
background also a financial background
trading background so i understand also
like
given like traveling between countries i
immediately understood the impact
this could have and then um but i wasn't
sure if i was going to go go all in
right so so you but and then i went to a
conference in december in vegas
in las vegas uh in in that conference
there was vitalik there was like charlie
lee there was matt rozek
the same crew um uh but that was like a
200 people conference uh in las vegas
and i
just thought that was a really nice
group a group of guys
back then the industry is much smaller
there's much less debate and contention
that you see on twitter these days
between different blockchains etc so uh
i remember some guy was teaching me
about ripple back then like how to set
up the
sort of gateways and stuff like that
yeah
and then in the process he transferred
like 500 us dollars worth of ripple to
me
and then um i said well now i learned it
let me transfer this back to you so i
had i all set up
he said just you know keep it and you
can send it to the next guy that you
teach
like well that's that's pretty nice um
so
it was like a community like that back
then so it wasn't like a it wasn't like
a
pure pump and dump or like so it was a
really nice community
so after that conference um i went back
said okay i'm gonna quit my job i'm
gonna
i wanted to do actually i want to do a
crypto exchange back then in my previous
uh
startup but the other funders or the
other the other partners said ah no
not not not sure so uh i said okay fine
then i'm not gonna
quit and then i'll join the bitcoin
industry
um and then a month later i was i began
to sell my house
um so started about a couple months
later um so it was early in 2014 i sold
it
um so this is when between july and
december bitcoin price went from about
100 us dollars to about
1300 us dollars um and then it was
coming back down by fluctuating a little
bit i was like oh no i got to buy it
quickly before it goes up again
so i bought a 600 us dollars average
price roughly for for that one million
dollars was pretty hard to get to buy
that that
that a month back then um and then
price drops to 200 i stayed there for
about two years
so i lost about two thirds of a house
for for a long time um it was mentally
uh stressful um but you know you didn't
sell did you
no i didn't say i still have those big
ones yeah so oh wow
oh wow strong hands easy you've got
strong hands
yeah so those are the bitcoins those are
the bitcoins i have
so um i never added more um and that
those are just the bitcoins i have so
yeah so so that's kind of how i got in
so yeah that's so insane i love that the
guy was like to you
oh yeah just do 10 and you're there like
a few months later no i'm going to do my
whole house
i don't want this house anymore i'm just
going to give it up basically
um yeah plus i quit my job too so i was
i was
jumping for like a month or so oh yeah
so
you gave up your house and your salary i
love that and that is dedication and you
didn't even sell
so with that in mind then you know
you're obviously very dedicated to
bitcoin your career is bitcoin
where do you think it's going i'm not
going to ask for a prediction um it's a
bit unfair
give one if you feel like it um but jim
what are you just what are your thoughts
in general on the market because you
know we thought we were going to see
all-time highs yesterday and we're sort
of back down to
16.8 which in my opinion is fantastic
numbers
um can't be crying at 16.8 at all
but what are your thoughts uh look yeah
i think yeah
short-term price predictions are
extremely difficult no one can do that
um but i think longer term so this is
also why i have held on to the bitcoins
i have
if you look at things long term um uh
look the industry has so much more room
to grow uh i think like look
look at any number today right so today
i think that's probably less than 2.2
percent of population in crypto
so it's got at least 500 x to go uh just
by that number from
that single metric it might be 0.1 to be
honest and
also um the bitcoin uh
the future financial world with crypto
is going to be much bigger than the fiat
financial
uh uh side market size this is similar
to
you should not evaluate uber's market
size using taxi market size because uber
can do a lot more that taxes cannot do
um and you should not be evaluating i
don't know an internet company using the
previous type of companies market
market potential and so crypto can do a
lot more
in terms of applications use cases etc
um and um i think it's going to be much
much bigger than the
than the current financial uh the future
crypto financial economy is going to be
much
much bigger than the current fiat one so
that's there's tons of room to grow
and also blockchain can be used outside
of financial uh
applications as well um uh land titles
anything that requires proof um super
supply chain management so
voting voting yes loading
yeah so like basically this there's a
lot more room to grow uh
so i i i think there's like a couple
thousand times
room to grow whether that's bitcoin or
not nobody knows but in the short term i
don't think bitcoin is going it's going
anywhere
so if you look at a day-to-day basis yes
markets will have
uh retractions market will have
fluctuations that's how
that's how markets work that's when you
put like i don't know a couple
a couple million people together to
trade that's that's what they do
um that's just my psychology um they
don't they don't they don't trade
according to a linear line so um yeah so
like in terms of predictions i think the
industry will get a lot bigger um so
i'm not worried about the price the
short-term price fluctuations at all so
that's also why i was able to hold
and that's how that's also why i think
this industry will be the fastest
growing industry for the next
few decades so uh and we're not we're
not just here for like two days
so we want to we want to be here for the
next 50 or 100 years
so yeah we'll see what happens my final
question
then for you um it kind of kind of just
linked off the back of that really
do you think that crypto can actually
replace fear
seriously a lot of people say you know
we see it working side by side
governments are creating you know
central bank digital currencies so
what do you think i think it's going to
take a while so it's not it's definitely
not going to happen overnight and it's
not going to happen
too quickly um i think anything that's
that deals with
a mass population especially like uh if
we're talking about like
everybody in the world there's like 200
different countries
um a few billion uh population
um it's gonna take a while so um i think
it's gonna be like a
at the at the most it's gonna be like
one slowly rising was slowly
decreasing i mean people still use uh uh
postal mail today people still use
emails today even though
it's the messenger is pretty pretty
popular now um
so i mean um there's there's bicycles
there's cars there's trains there's
airplanes so people still use quite a
lot of those different things
so i don't know which situation it's
going to be but more likely it's going
to be
probably going to be more similar to uh
postal mail versus email though
so i think they will be um i think most
likely
by any logical understanding of
cryptocurrencies it is much much better
than
fiat it has a lot of properties it
overcomes a lot of the
difficulties or or shortcomings of our
fiat currencies
so it does have a lot of advantages so
um but
i don't think it's gonna happen anytime
soon
um there's also a there's a learning
curve for mass population alone even
though
even if it's 100 better and there are
also some deficiencies in
cryptocurrencies as well
most people don't know how to hold
cryptocurrencies securely today
i most people cannot like even if you
give them a hardware wallet they don't
know how to
securely store the backup so the
application is not quite there yet for
mass adoption
so it's gonna take a number of years but
those those issues will be overcome
so yeah i'm very polish good
yeah i agree the user experience is
something which we sort of need to up
our game on um but it doesn't happen
overnight i totally agree with you
cece i want to thank you so much it's
been such a pleasure
um you know we always hear about you you
know you're the founder of finance but
we never get to learn about
you um so i want to thank you so much
for taking the time and i know it's late
but
all the way in asia and where you are so
thank you so much for coming on it's
been such a pleasure
yeah thanks thanks for having us thanks
for having me it's no more working hours
for me so anyway
not a problem it's a pleasure yeah
thanks so much and thank you thank you
for everyone for tuning in
and we will see you next week on
thursday bye bye
[Music]
uh